[Music]
on this Sunday night a tense holiday
crossover
the latest flare-ups in the Middle East
is Easter Ramadan and Passover overlap
the Pope's Easter Sunday plea for peace
here at home an Easter weekend without
we still have a full Workforce in the
field today power problems continue to
plague tens of thousands in Quebec plus
food insecurity at crisis levels in
Canada's biggest city it's the work in
corn and Canada's baseball team is back
along with a beloved former manager I
feel like I'm one of you man Gibby on
the new baseball rules and a revamped
Roger Center
global national with Fara Nasser
Ole
thousands of Catholic faithful gathered
in Saint Peter's square at the Vatican
today as Pope Francis presided over
Easter Sunday mass in his sermon the
pontiff included prayers of comfort for
victims of various conflicts raging
across the world and made an urgent call
for peace from Russia's invasion of
Ukraine to the escalating crisis between
the Israelis and Palestinians that's
only growing deadlier
good evening and thank you for joining
us those prayers for peace in the Middle
East are nowhere near answered as
tensions remain high this weekend this
past holy week has been marred by
violence in the region from Israeli
forces beating Muslim worshipers and a
mosque to deadly attacks on civilians
from Palestinian groups and that's on
top of Israel's growing political
instability Israel looks at the
situation and the latest escalation in
our top story tonight
Easter Passover and Ramadan all poseid
this year
shadow of heightened tensions the
Israeli military says its warplanes
struck Syrian Army sites in retaliation
for a rocket attack
a Palestinian group based in Damascus
claimed responsibility calling it
retribution for the storming of Al-Aqsa
mosque
Israeli forces entered the Muslim holy
site last week beating worshipers
on Sunday the situation was calmer but
still uneasy Palestinians performed
prayers inside Al-Aqsa as Jewish
worshipers walked up to the site they
call the Temple mount
in the occupied West Bank mourners
gathered at the funeral of two British
Israeli sisters
killed when a suspected Palestinian
gunman opened fire Friday
they died the same day a car rammed into
a group of pedestrians in Tel Aviv
killing an Italian tourist
Palestinians also buried their dead the
family of a 20-year-old man says Israeli
soldiers shot and killed him during
clashes
what happened is a crime against this
town says his uncle Israeli forces hate
our young men the last time there were
Mass protests Mira sukharov is a
political scientist who studies the
conflict
the flare-up also comes at a time when
Israel is facing unprecedented turmoil
from within
anti-government demonstrations are
sweeping the country against what
protesters call a power grab by prime
minister Benjamin netanyahu's Coalition
right-wing government there can't be
democracy which is the term they're
chanting in the streets democracy there
cannot be democracy without it being
Democratic for all including the
Palestinians under Israeli control
political instability and growing
uncertainty during a sacred time for
Christians Jews and Muslims tariya isri
Global News Ottawa
a delegation of Canadian MPS is heading
to Taiwan the latest group of foreign
dignitaries to visit the island as a
show of solidarity but as Taiwan
prepares to receive its Canadian guests
it's also dealing with Chinese
aggression China is set to begin its
third and final day of military drills
in the region in what Beijing calls a
Stern warning to the self-governing
island as Redmond Shannon reports the
war games have sparked fears of a much
larger International conflict looming
taiwan's Coast Guard issuing a warning
to a Chinese Navy vessel
you are seriously harming Regional peace
stability and Security Police
immediately turn around and leave on
Sunday taiwan's defense Ministry says it
spotted 11 Chinese ships and 70 military
aircraft as Beijing forces simulated
Precision strikes against the Democratic
Island that China regards as its own the
drills represented by this animation on
Chinese State tv taiwan's military eager
to show its preparedness with videos
like these with more Chinese exercises
expected on Monday
the timing is no coincidence coming just
after the visit of taiwan's President
Tsai inguin to the U.S Taiwan is
grateful
outside president tsai's predecessor and
political opponent in Taiwan spent time
touring mainland China this week May Yen
Joe preferring closer ties with Beijing
rather than Washington
our Administration continues to lead
Taiwan to Danger he said the future is a
choice between peace or War some
analysts say next year's elections in
Taiwan and the U.S could be crucial for
the Island's future the United States
and China need to find a way to deal
with this issue in a constructive manner
because if there is a conflict over the
Taiwan Straits it would be catastrophic
for the global economy the U.S believes
China could have the capacity to invade
Taiwan by 2027 but some in Washington
believe it may never get that far China
is going to try to influence this next
election and take over the island
without a shot fire that is an assertion
that may attract attention in Ottawa a
group of Canadian MPS is heading to
Taiwan this week for a scheduled visit
something that is unlikely to improve
relations between China and Canada
Redmond Shannon double news London
residents in the German city of Hamburg
are being told to shut their windows and
stay indoors tonight after a major fire
at a warehouse sent thick black smoke
and possible toxins all over the city
oh
this is the stream of smoke that could
be seen drifting toward the city center
today as emergency officials wearing gas
masks could be seen responding to the
fire officials say about 140 people were
evacuated from the immediate vicinity of
the fire and it's still not clear will
cause The Blaze
back here in Canada Quebec is still
grappling with the aftermath of last
week's Fierce ice storm Hydro Quebec
says by Monday it hopes to reconnect
power to the tens of thousands of
customers who are still without
electricity but there are warnings that
some will have to hold out a little
longer than that and as Elizabeth
zigalis reports that weight is already
bringing its own set of health risks
broken trees branches and debris still
litter the streets of Montreal as the
city and hydro Quebec continue their
efforts to clean and repair all the
damages in the aftermath of Wednesday's
ice storm we still have a full Workforce
in the field today so more than 1500
people over 100 000 customers across
Quebec were still without power on
Easter Sunday but there is light at the
end of the tunnel our goal is to restore
up to 95 percent of our customers by the
end of today tree branches falling on
power lines has been a major challenge
for workers in the aftermath of the
storm but the budget dedicated to
trimming trees has doubled since 2016
and hydro Quebec says it could have been
worse we've seen the benefit there and
will continue our work in that program
meanwhile Montreal Public Health
easily 10 times what we usually see in a
year as of Sunday Dr Kaiser says there
are around 180 cases of illness due to
the poisonous gas we are fortunate we
haven't had any of this and we're really
uh want to keep it that way we have had
several severe cases and so those are
people who then need treatment in
hospital and we want to avoid that a 75
year old man died after he was found
unconscious in his garage on Thursday
where he had been using a diesel powered
generator at his home Northwest of
Montreal but Montreal Public Health
would like to avoid more never use
anything that burns wood fuel oil gas
indoors Dr Kaiser is also urging people
to be aware of food poisoning many
families have had to throw food away the
province announced some grocery stores
could remain open on Easter Sunday to
help residents running low on food After
the Blackout Elizabeth ogales Global
News Montreal
in Winnipeg one of the city's biggest
shelters says Rising costs could force
it to run a deficit for the first time
in the organization's history Silo
Mission says the ballooning cost of food
is largely to blame
this year it's the first time that we've
had to budget a significant increase in
food because the donations are down at
the same time that the amount of food
that we need to get out the door to
folks has significantly increased
the organization says it's averaging
1500 meals a day right now that's double
what it was providing just a few years
ago
but it's not just climbing food prices a
lack of affordable housing and limited
bumps in Pay make food insecurity a
major concern for people right across
our country Amar Khan visited one of
Canada's largest food banks as workers
there say they're at a Breaking Point
amid an unprecedented spike in need
[Music]
hundreds of volunteers working on Easter
weekend to assist their fellow
torontonians making sure everyone has
food on the table it's just a good thing
to do in general and it's really nice to
help people especially people that don't
have what other people are able to get
the additional help comes at a time in
which food prices are rising and at the
Daily Bread Food Bank the demand is ever
growing more people than ever are
relying on the food bank while food
costs are up and inflation is a
contributing factor before the pandemic
Daily Bread Food Bank spent 1.5 million
dollars a year on food now they're
spending 1.8 million dollars a month on
food or 21.2 million a year to feed
people in Toronto we are in a crisis
situation we have never experienced food
insecurity in the city of Toronto like
we're experiencing it now the
organization has seen its clientele
balloon during the course of the
pandemic they used to serve around 65
000 people month but it's since grown to
270 000 more than four times for
reference that's more than the
population of the city of Kitchener and
could fill the Roger Center five times
over and at least 35 percent of the food
demands are coming from college educated
torontonians working a full-time job
individuals who are coming to food banks
are the folks that you're sitting beside
on the subway or are sitting across from
you in a cubicle it's the work
importance individuals who know fault of
their own find themselves struggling to
get by and are food insecure now the
food bank is urging all levels of
government to step in either to increase
disability support payments or provide
an immediate surge of funding we are
growing at an unsustainable rate of
course we need food and of course we
need funds but what we need most is
advocacy to be able to provide for
individuals whose incomes simply don't
meet the bills that they need to pay as
advocates ask for help from various
levels of government they're stressing
urgency noting that demand food banks
isn't going to be slowing down anytime
soon Amar Khan Global News
the political potency of crime coming up
watching United conservative party is
banking on tough Public Safety policies
ahead of the Alberta election
Alberta is now just a few weeks away
from an election and the governing
United conservatives are trying to make
their case for staying in power by
focusing attention on crime now that's
not usually a top voting issue but it's
happening as many Canadian cities see a
surge in violent crime raising concerns
around stranger attacks Heather York's
West looks at whether this tough on
crime strategy could politically pay off
early morning attack on a Calgary c
train Tuesday brought a sense of here we
go again in recent weeks violence on
Transit lines has been making headlines
across the country Edmonton's police
chief says the surge is real
31.4 percent increase in calls for
service for police and Transit violent
calls for service increase of 52.8
and approximately 70 percent of that
violence was unprovoked random attacks
on our transit system it's why with an
election less than two months away
Alberta's United conservative party is
promising to get tough on crime
announcing a plan to recruit 100 new
police officers in Calgary and Edmonton
one day and accusing NDP candidates of
being anti-police at a campaign event
the next these candidates are harboring
deep-seated resentment against our men
and women in uniform absolutely this is
about emotion you know people vote with
their brain and people vote with their
heart weeks after the tragic deaths of
two Edmonton Police constables in the
line of duty this political scientist
says a pro-police tough on crime
campaign strategy could succeed but will
it make cities safer no the tough on
crime approach is about
appearing to make a difference and it's
more about the theatrics and the Optics
of whoever's trying to get elected
sending someone to prison ends whatever
support that they have if they did have
some sort of housing they lose it if
they didn't have a mental health Team
supporting them they typically lose that
as well it's why some experts believe
from a public safety perspective more
dollars spent on policing isn't likely
to be money well spent still with
emotions running High there could be
political benefits Heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
[Music]
I had shifting to the left how one
political race could signal a changing
tide in American politics
it has been a whirlwind week in American
politics as former U.S president Donald
Trump used his historic indictment as a
rallying cry to reunite Republicans but
it's a seismic shake-up in Wisconsin
Supreme Court that has Democrats
celebrating one that could change
Washington for years to come Eric
Sorensen explains
strange as it may seem the day Donald
Trump was forced to trudge into court
his political fundraising shot up and
his grip on the Republican Presidential
nomination became more certain as the
party rallied around him they think
they're going to take him out but what
it's doing is it's just making him
stronger but on that very day far from
the hubbub in Manhattan out in Wisconsin
a vote for a single seat on the state
supreme court showed the political
ground continuing to shift in America
soon you'll head to the polls millions
of dollars from out of state poured in
for a liberal judge who campaigned
openly to overturn Wisconsin's ban on
abortions judge Janet proteowitz
believes in women's freedom to make
their own decisions when it comes to
abortion conservative former Justice
Daniel Kelly campaigned against her we
can't afford to have judges who put
their own agendas above the law but that
agenda including abortion rights brought
out many Women Voters I think that
everyone should be able to make their
own choices about their own bodies and
the Wisconsin uh Supreme Court race is
super important Wisconsin's high court
has had a conservative majority 4-3 for
15 years until last Tuesday
foreign
[Applause]
has tipped the balance of the court to
the Liberals they've chosen to reject
partisan extremism in this state
what stunned political analysts was that
it wasn't close in a 50-50 State she won
by 11 points you're seeing incredible
enthusiasm from Liberal voters and
you're seeing a continued shift a
continued erosion for republicans in
those Suburban areas was it abortion was
it Trump was it a combination of those
things as president Donald Trump and his
Supreme Court nominees succeeded in
overturning the right to abortion but at
the state level that has mobilized
progressives to fight back as a result
of the Supreme Court's success there's a
counter push which are bringing
Progressive Democrats to power the
significances that Wisconsin is a swing
state and does this suggest a
progressive wave of Ripple coming
forward Donald Trump's indictment in New
York may be shaking up the Republican
race in his favor but it's in Wisconsin
and other swing states where a tectonic
shift in American politics appears to be
taking place Eric Sorensen Global News
[Music]
a ballpark a look inside the revamp
space housing Canada's baseball team
[Music]
it's been a strange start to the
baseball season for the Toronto Blue
Jays who began the year on a lengthy
road trip due to Renovations at their
home stadium one person eager to see the
reopening of the Rogers Center is former
manager John Gibbons who's found a
second career covering the sport in a
different way Mike drolet caught up with
a Texan who still has a soft spot for
all things Canadian
at long last baseball is back in the Big
Smoke anyway I gotta get my grill ready
right woke up this morning I'm ready to
go you might remember John Gibbons there
grizzled Cowboy of a manager from the
last time the Jays were chasing
championships you also might have
noticed it's a different game now with
new rules he likes to ban on suppressive
defenses but hates the pitch clock to
speed up games overall no I don't I
don't like all the change part of a 300
million dollar facelift the Rogers
Center underwent this off season the
area Beyond The Outfield has essentially
been torn out and replaced with areas
for socializing a mix of rooftop patios
bars and food vendors Gibbons is
planning to return to Canada this summer
and says that's where you'll find him
out there with the common man that's
yeah that's that's my crime man it turns
out even a true blue Texan can Embrace
change of course it says nothing on the
culture shock he first experienced in
Toronto where the fans loved him for his
one-liners and even occasionally trading
blows with his own players what is
that with Canadians
you know I
I don't mean to insult any you Canadians
it's I I think I feel like I'm one of
you man you know you guys are you guys
are a lot like Texans down here you know
the stupidest stuff you put on there the
more people like yeah
this is perfect there's four man you
can't you can't skirt you can't sneak by
and give it a crappy effort or in uh and
I think that's
Canadians you give them a good effort
man and you busted every night and you
know what
they'll love you oh they sure will Mike
trelay Global News at Toronto
the whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your Easter
evening with us tonight's here Canada is
this hot air balloon near High River
Alberta we love senior Canada so please
keep emailing us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
will be with you on the anchor desk
tomorrow until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
thank you